hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is the Korean language or
handle mail as it's called in Korean and
actually in North Korea it's called
Chosun my Korean is one of the major
languages of Northeast Asia it's spoken
as a first language by a total of around
80 million people including around 50
million in South Korea 25 million in
North Korea and around 2.5 million in
China including the Jung Byung and Chong
BEC Korean autonomous areas which are
both in Jilin province near the border
with North Korea it's also spoken by
minorities in Japan Russia and numerous
other countries throughout the world the
roots of the Korean language are unclear
and are the subject of much debate some
think it's a member of the Altaic
language family alongside Turkic
mongolic and Tengu sick and japonic
languages but these days the Altai ik
language family is no longer widely
accepted or shall we say it's unproven
others think that korean shares ancient
roots with the Dravidian languages of
southern india and sri lanka and there's
another theory that korean derives from
the Austronesian language family but
there's no definitive proof for any of
these theories so Korean is often
defined as a language isolate the sole
member of the chorionic language family
the lack of evidence for any of these
theories is largely because of the lack
of samples of older korean writing the
oldest samples that we are aware of are
less than a thousand years old and the
written and chinese characters making
them hard to decipher old korean the
first century CE II marked the beginning
of the Three Kingdoms period on the
Korean Peninsula and Manchuria the
kingdoms were Co Korea Peck je and
Shilla it's not known for sure just how
closely the languages of these kingdoms
were related they may have all been
closely related dialects of old Korean
or they may have been distinct members
of the chorionic language family from
limited information mainly place names
it appears that the languages were
similar but not exactly the same there
may have been two groups of chorionic
languages the Puyo group including Puyo
co korea and puia peck je and the hun
group which included Shilla in South
Korea it's widely believed that Shilla
is the direct
ancestor of modern Korean in North Korea
it's widely believed that Goguryeo is
the direct ancestor of modern Korean
during the unified silla period
beginning in the 7th century when Shilla
conquered the other kingdoms the Shilla
variety became the dominant language of
the peninsula this is the form of old
Korean that became the ancestor of
middle Korean Korea has been
tremendously influenced by China
throughout its history due to invasion
attempts alliances and extensive trade
the influence on Korean culture includes
stunning influence on the Korean
language since Korean didn't have its
own writing system it adopted the
Chinese writing system and used it well
into the era of middle Korean and a huge
amount of Chinese vocabulary entered
Korean through the literary language
middle Korean when the Korea dynasty
began in the 10th century the capital
moved to Kaesong so the Kaesong dialect
became the prestige language it seems
that by this time the peninsula
basically spoke the same language so
this was simply a dialectal change the
first written record of Korean that we
know of
beyond place names comes from this time
period the sources Chinese and gives a
few hundred examples of Korean words
written phonetically using Chinese
characters one feature of middle Korean
is that it featured four tones and on
top of that Chinese loanwords still
retained their tones as well these tone
distinctions have disappeared in modern
Standard Korean but there are a couple
of dialects that do retain some of these
distinctions we know that middle Korean
had tones because there were markings
indicating tone in the Hangul writing
system which was created in 1444 by King
Sejong the great of the Chosun dynasty
Hangul was created to increase literacy
among the poor and people without a
formal education prior to the creation
of Hangul Korean went through a number
of different writing systems that used
Chinese characters in various ways to
represent Korean none of which were an
ideal match for Korean or very easy to
learn in the beginning elites and
scholars opposed the introduction of
Hangul but over the following centuries
it became widespread and Hangul is such
an ingenious writing system that it's
really hard to imagine how
wouldn't have become widespread for a
long time Korean was often written and
published in a mixed script using
Hangzhou Chinese characters for content
words and Hangul for functional or
grammatical words and inflections it was
quite similar to how Japanese is still
written today speaking of Japanese Korea
was occupied by Japan from 1910 until
1945 during the occupation Japanese was
made the official language and policies
were implemented that would have
replaced Korean with Japanese if the
occupation had not been ended Japanese
was made the language of Education
except for Korean class and speaking
Korean at school was banned Koreans were
pressured to replace their Korean names
with Japanese names and Korean language
newspapers were ordered to shut down
these assimilationist policies were
gradually introduced and speeded up in
the later years of the occupation
thankfully the Korean language survived
the occupation but a significant amount
of Japanese vocabulary was absorbed into
the language in the decades since the
occupation ended honja have gradually
become de-emphasized in favor of Hangul
nowadays most texts are written entirely
or mostly in Hangul
with han chaeah mainly used to prevent
possible ambiguity between homophones
and in North Korea specifically hangzhou
were eliminated from all official
publications in 1949 I'm going to
speculate that the growing emphasis on
Hangul was partly a reaction to the
Japanese occupation that a growing sense
of Korean sovereignty made the Korean
people want to use more of their
nation's homegrown script the existence
of the Hangul script is now celebrated
every year on Hangul day October 9th in
South Korea and on Chosun cool day
January 15th in North Korea both Koreas
have a literacy rate of over 99% so I
guess there is reason to celebrate
so what's Korean like well there's a lot
to say about Korean and there's no way I
can give a complete comprehensive
overview of the whole language in a
single video but we'll look at some of
its important features Tongo Tongo is a
fantastic writing system that you can
learn to read very quickly there is a
basic set of consonant and vowel symbols
that are arranged together to form
compact syllables this says Hangul this
symbolism huh this
is ah this is mm this is good this is
and this is oh this system is ingenious
because once you get used to the most
common combinations of symbols then you
can instantly recognize them the
consonant symbols fall into groups of
different letters these consonants are
velar and the basic shape shows the
tongues position in the mouth this point
indicates the place of articulation near
the back of the mouth these consonants
are alveolar x' and the basic shape
shows the tongue touching the roof of
the mouth these consonants are by labial
and the basic shape shows a mouth with
two lips these consonants are dentals
and the basic shape shows the place of
articulation at the upper teeth these
consonants are glottal and the basic
shape shows that the place of
articulation is in your throat
vocabulary in most current examples of
written Korean all or almost all of the
words are written in Hangul including
native Korean words and sino-korean
words words of Chinese origin believe it
or not sino-korean words account for
over 60% of Korean vocabulary their most
prevalent in formal and academic
vocabulary but they're very common in
everyday speech as well let's look at
the Chinese vocabulary that appears in
the following sentences this sentence
means do you like your teacher
so using memes hua Hale notice the word
Sun sang which means teacher
this word is of Chinese origin this
sentence means what's your phone number
Chon Abu Nidal ale the words for
telephone and number are of Chinese
origin when Korean is written in a mixed
hunga hunga script you can more easily
identify the sino-korean words and you
can more easily distinguish between
words that sound the same because they
are written with different Chinese
characters but these days they are
mainly written in Hangul Korean also
contains more recent loan words from
other languages mainly English words
like choose meaning juice puku meaning
fork sin do Ichi meaning sandwich
obviously the pronunciation of these
words has naturally changed and become
suited to Korean phonology some loan
words are abbreviated or used in ways
that the original words were not used
for example the word saved con means
selfie which came from the words self
and camera
another example Ayesha open means
window-shopping and comes from the words
eye and shopping sentence structure
korean is a verb final language with the
verb at the end of the sentence
a typical sentences sov this sentence
means I play baseball nan in Yahoo
inhale here's the subject na here's the
object ya goo and here's the verb heyo
it's also possible to save this sentence
with no subject if it's clear from the
context but let's go back to the
original sentence for a minute in
addition to the subject object and verb
there are two other words in the
sentence
these words are particles words that are
placed after nouns to indicate their
function or relationship to other words
in the sentence rule is a direct object
marker showing that yah goo baseball is
the object of the verb lo is the form
that follows a word ending in a vowel o
is the form that follows words ending in
a consonant nun is a topic marker the
form that comes afterwards ending in a
consonant is own na is the subject of
the sentence but it's also the topic
that means na is information that has
previously been mentioned or as clear
from the context in that it's the topic
being elaborated on there are also
subject markers e after a consonant and
cop after a vowel subject markers are
used to introduce new information or to
introduce the importance of existing
information in other words to emphasize
it we could change the sentence above to
make not the subject de gallo guru Hale
notice that na is pronounced as nae when
followed by a car in the pronunciation
of car changes to gah in this sentence
daga shows that I is the new information
or emphasized information this might be
said in response to a question asking
who plays baseball in English we might
stress this subject like I play baseball
here's another example of when you might
use the subject marker real mother
panatela say the sentence means my
mother entered the room actually this
part literally means our mother but it's
used to mean my when referring to your
own in-group anyway in this case my
mother is new information because before
that she wasn't
present she wasn't in the room so the
subject particle is suitable here this
word here a is another particle showing
Direction like the english preposition
to or into but technically speaking
since the particle comes after the noun
it's a post position rather than a
preposition in korean modifiers come
before the things that they modify that
means that adjectives come before nouns
do Pinton this means a tall mountain
this is the word for tall and this is
the word for mountain this part in
connects the adjective to the noun
longer modifiers also come before the
noun you want them to modify this phrase
means the mountain i want to climb naega
lugozshe printin word for word this
phrase is i subject marker climb want
connector mountain but if we take the
whole modifying clause as a single unit
this modifier plus noun pattern is like
saying the i want to climb mountain so
whereas in english the modifier would
come after the noun in korean it comes
before by the way this sentence could
mean a mountain i want to climb with
indefinite meaning korean doesn't have
definite or indefinite articles so
definiteness can be understood from
context verbs and adjectives every
sentence in korean must end in either a
verb or an adjective and verbs and
adjectives act very similar to each
other in korean with both being
conjugated for past or non past and for
different politeness levels first let's
look at verbs the dictionary form of
verbs all end in da for example this
verb made an meaning to stop and this
verb chata meaning to sleep in order to
conjugate these verbs you remove da and
you are left with the verb stem which
you add affixes to so let's conjugate
these verbs in the present tense or non
past tense to be precise this sentence
means he stops eating
Koonin Bob tomorrow so look at how we
conjugate the verb to stop the stem is
mul the informal present tense ending is
aa and the polite suffix is yo so this
is the informal polite conjugation for
verb stems whose final vowel sound is R
or all this verb ends in a consonant but
when the verb ends in the vowel R then
only your
is added for example Coonans Heil he
sleeps
note that with either of these verbs you
could remove yo to make an informal non
polite sentence in other words a more
casual sentence if the stem ends in a
it's replaced with IO here's an example
with the verb meaning to try as Saddam
could do de Nesle
this sentence means they try if the last
vowel of the stem is are you or E or a
combined vowel then AA or IO is added to
the stem not done again we have the verb
meaning to eat Nannan topokki remove oil
this sentence means
I eat topokki let's take a look at how
the past tense is formed by changing
some of those sentences into the past
before we had this sentence Coonan bob
de Mayo meaning he stops eating let's
change this to he stopped eating in the
past Coonan bob de maras sale he sleeps
[ __ ] inhale
he slept [ __ ] enjoys soil let's remove
the polite suffix yo for a moment notice
that the past tense form equals the
present tense form with this affix saw
attached then to make it polite we can
add yo future tense Korean technically
doesn't have a future tense only passed
and non past but there are ways to
express the future the most common being
the probable future form to use the
probable future form you add little
calle o to the verb stem
Nannan tokido mago ale this sentence
means I'm going to eat topokki when
talking about things aside from yourself
the probable future refers to things
that you think are likely to happen but
when referring to yourself
it shows determination rather than
speculation so we can translate this as
I'm going to eat topokki
or I shall eat to pogey by the way I'm
probably pronouncing this word top pogi
the way it's pronounced in Japanese I
live in Japan so I've eaten a lot more
topokki here than in Korea adjectives
when an adjective is in the predicative
position in other words after the
subject then it functions similarly to a
verb and is conjugated sani new pile the
sentence means the mountain is tall the
present tense Afric and polite affix are
added to the adjectives stem just like a
verb
and we can make this past tense to sani
new peso the mountain was tall this is
conjugated just like a past tense verb
speech levels when looking at verbs in
the previous section we looked mainly at
the informal polite forms of verbs like
Mario from Merida and I briefly
mentioned that we could make the
informal non polite form by removing yo
like Mara these are two of seven
politeness levels in Korean
luckily for learners not all seven of
them are commonly used three or maybe
four are commonly used the other two are
formal polite man Mita and formal non
polite manda the informal polite form is
used when speaking to friends and
acquaintances colleagues of a similar
status to you shop staff etc the
informal non polite form is used when
speaking to very close friends a brother
or sister
someone a few years younger than you or
someone you want to be rude to the
formal polite form is used when speaking
to someone of higher status than you and
people you are meeting for the first
time the formal non polite form is
basically a neutral form that you can
use when you don't know who the reader
or listener is in other words when
you're speaking to many types of people
it can also be used in speaking to
friends of the same age range let's look
at a couple more sentences in Korean and
see what we find this sentence means I
have a bicycle but I don't have a car
none in Hodgenville I sell hajiman tacos
so word-for-word it's AI topic marker
bicycle subject marker there is but car
subject marker there isn't this sentence
shows us how to express possession or
have in Korean the topic of the sentence
is the possessor then the thing that is
possessed is the subject of the sentence
with a subject marker followed by the
existence verb meaning there is or there
are
then we start a new sentence with but
and there is a subject car with a
subject marker followed by the negative
verb of existence meaning there isn't or
there aren't notice that there's no
topic in the second sentence the topic
can be skipped if it's already clear
another sentence this means this food is
delicious did you cook it you Michigan
mush so the
so word-for-word it's this food topic
marker delicious informal polite
conjugation you subject marker cooking
did informal non polite conjugation this
first sentence follows a very common
pattern here's the subject which is also
the topic of the sentence with a topic
marker and before the noun we can see
the demonstrative e meaning this and
here we have the adjective which is
conjugated like a verb in the second
sentence the subject is the word for you
followed by the subject marker kah Yoli
is the word for cooking or cuisine and
haisa is the verb meaning do conjugated
in the past tense informal non polite
form this is the same as the informal
polite form with the syllable yo removed
from the end of both sentences when
talking directly to someone it's very
common to drop the subject pronoun for
example judy has so but in this case the
subject and subject marker kah are
included to emphasize you like did you
cook it as opposed to someone else
next we see something very common and
important in Korean we have a verb that
consists of two parts a noun of Chinese
origin followed by the verb hada which
means to do or to make many many Korean
verbs are constructed this way for
example inada meaning to work kun da
meaning to study there were also some
words of English origin that form verbs
this way for example Sawada meaning to
shower let's look at one last sentence
conan-kun hot singing ale this sentence
means she is a good student
word-for-word it's she topic marker good
connector student be informal polite so
here we have the subject which is also
the topic with a topic marker then we
have the adjective meaning good and
since it comes before the noun there's a
connector Huck sang means student and
the verb is at the end this verb is the
informal polite form of EDA which
basically means to be and usually comes
after nouns there is also a negative
form of this verb anita so we could make
this sentence negative like this Coonans
hoon singing on Yale now the sentence
means she is not a good student
notice that in the negative form of this
sentence the subject marker II comes
after axing so with this particular verb
you have the topic and then the
complement actually becomes the subject
of the sentence there's really so much
more I could say about Korean and
there's no way I can cover everything in
a single video but hopefully that gave
you a taste of the language and sparked
your interest in some ways Korean is
strikingly similar to Japanese but in
some ways it's quite different you might
want to check out my video from a couple
of years ago on the differences and
similarities between Korean and Japanese
be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and once
again thank you to all of my wonderful
patreon supporters especially my
top-tier patreon supporters right here
on the screen many thanks to them and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice day
[Music]